Today we have learned that netanyaju has declared non
grata to the United Nations in Israel.
This means that its staff will not have visas to travel to the ground.
And this is a consequence of the fact that neither netanyaju nor the State
of Israel has never been stopped in its policy of illegal occupation of
Palestinian territory in the last decades.
There are 4 things that European states can do immediately The first to suspend
diplomatic relations with the state Israel The second to establish firm economic
sanctions as were done with Putin's leadership arms embargo in third place
and in 4th place as was also done in the case of the Ukrainian war to bring
netanyaju and all political leaders who are carrying out bombings against
civilian population before the criminal court international Let's still act
Is it possible to stop the genocide?